do you start every screenplay out with
an outline I first start with a notebook
once I decided okay this is a project
that I want to write I buy a notebook
for it I usually try to sort of theme
the notebook so if it's like old like
pirate adventure I'll try to make it
look I'll find a notebook that looks
like that and then I will just use that
notebook to just freehand write anything
I'm interested in in regards to this
screenplay whether it's just like a very
vague idea of I think this thing should
happen or I'm writing dialogue for a
scene that might exist in the stream I'm
sort of filling that notebook up and I
don't really have a timeline at that
point so I'm talking about specs scripts
for me I'm just writing it writing it
write it until hopefully a story will
coalesce and once I feel like that
story's coalesced I'll try to write that
story as succinctly impossible
essentially I'm trying to write the log
line for it and if that log line is
engaging to me and I think will move me
if I think that story that is told even
in that little you know one sentence is
moving enough to me I'll try to take
that sentence and I'll turn it into a
paragraph and if that paragraph is
moving then I'll move on if it's not I
will continue to maybe reshape that
paragraph and then that paragraph will
become a page that page will become
multiple pages into sort of a treatment
and then if the treatment that's when I
think I'm doing most of my story work
I'm writing that over and over and I
will do that for a couple a months maybe
depending on how often I can work on it
and once that treatment is really
resonating with me and is a story that
again will move me then I can take it
and start writing the draft and so it
almost feels like that draft is more
like a translation project than writing
something new I'm taking something that
exists in full prose writing
and then put it into a screenplay format
and so all of the little things that
exist in a screenplay that's when I'm
putting those things in because my story
I feel I already feel incredibly
comfortable about so I don't have to
discover any of the story things they
just discover all those little things
all those little nooks and crannies that
happen when a story is now gonna be put
on the screen and I'm translating it
there and then I'll get that first draft
and then from that I'm moving into
rewrites and polishes and all those sort
of conversations but I think it's helped
me because I feel like my story usually
doesn't go through too many significant
changes once I'm on that draft once I'm
in the screenplay software and writing
it because all those changes I've hit
all those dead ends all those things
that I thought were great that are not
all those things that I was excited
about that didn't end up doing anything
for me I've already figured that out in
that treatment process so I don't
outline so much as try to just tell a
story and tell it fuller and fuller
until that's a full rich story and then
translate it to a screenplay if that
makes sense
it does so it almost sounds like this
little notebook that you buy this themed
it's like a scrapbook yeah okay so then
you're putting it's almost like a diet
part diary parts scrapbook you're just
putting little notes and it's like it's
like filling up and then by the time you
get to the screenplay formatting it's
already its own world in that little
book yeah it already exists and I have
this full treatment that was pretty
detailed and it tells a story so it's
not an outline because I don't so I
don't have to discover how this
character is going to convince this
other character of what they want
because I've done that in the treatment
but now I get to in the screenplay
figure out what are the exact words that
she's using to convince this character
about what she wants or something like
that so a lot of the work is for me
compared to how I think some other
people I've heard their process some of
that work is kind of split where it's
story stuff here and
then sort of screenplay stuff over here
when I'm in the software and and doing
all the screenplay formatting and stuff
like that
are there any pictures to help flush it
out no I actually don't use pictures I
think it's because I'm a horrible artist
and I don't do clippings or anything
that I think in every way I've ever been
creative it's always been in words and
ideas and so anytime I've ever tried to
translate any of my creative ideas
through visual stuff it just never works
and so I'm just I've just I think given
up on that for now maybe at some point I
will try to learn how to draw or
something like that but it's probably
why I do I'm a lot more active on
Twitter than I am on Instagram because
that's just where I feel the most
comfortable
sure well Instagram is also very
personal and like a this is what I had
for lunch and you know there's a great
photo of it and yeah here's me you know
with so-and-so and some people that you
know it's just they're they're just
better sharing links to articles or
talking about writing or something yeah
yeah do you ever go back and look at
those notebooks during the process or
afterwards even years later like oh wow
this is this notebook for this so this
notebook became this thing yeah I mean I
have them on my shelf and I can see
because they're all different I can make
oh that's that project that's that one
and I mean now and then I might flip
through one and like oh yeah I had that
idea for that scene that never ended up
anywhere but there's something I love
about this idea this this scene and it
didn't have a home in this project I
thought it did but maybe it'll go
elsewhere or I'll see something and I
think to myself why did I ever think
that was interesting like who was I at
that point that wrote that little scrap
of an idea and why was i interested in
that so it's not just a useful tool
creatively
but personally it acts as a little bit
of sort of like an idea diary of what I
was interested at the time that I wrote
that thing I think it's cool to that you
have it in the theme of whatever the
project is yeah and I definitely have
notebooks that are empty but I was like
that's a cool notebook but I can't use
it yet because I don't have an idea that
fits the feeling of that notebook
and sometimes it the notebook itself
will get me going oh I should write a
fantasy novel because that notebook
looks like a fantasy novel or something
like that
I forget which author it was that said
don't buy really pretty notebooks to put
like your feelings in or creative right
whatever because you're gonna be too
precious because it's so beautiful if
you buy something that it's not even you
don't care too much about it's like the
spiral notebook from the 99-cent store
you're just gonna be like cool I can put
whatever I want I can just regurgitate
it all here and I don't have to be
precious with it
mm-hmm I don't know that's just a
thought but there's so many beautiful
notebooks that you see in bookstores if
people go to bookstores anymore but I
remember back in the day you know and it
would almost be too intimidating to
writing something that's leather-bound
and I feel that way I keep a personal
journal and it's a lovely leather-bound
journal as a gift for my sister years
ago and I am a little bit intimidated to
write because the notebooks for my
screenplays I'm just collecting scraps
of ideas and I feel like I'm just kind
of spilling my brain out onto it but my
personal journal I feel like what if
someone finds this and reads it I want
it to be thoughtful and interesting and
I want I want to appear smart even
though it's for me I'm still thinking
some how about how this might be seen by
others and it's because this notebook
feels like it's something that would be
read by others whereas those other
notebooks for my screenplays it's like
if that is read by others that's great
because it's it's not supposed to be a
thing it's not supposed to be readable
but if this Diary would be something
that would be red I would be terrified
and even though it's not I'm still
terrified and I think it's because it's
a really nice turtle
sure sure and it's not you you want to
write in the King's English
yeah pen or something you know what's
the other one you put whatever profanity
just whatever thoughts yes my house you
would be doing that yes my handwriting
is also terrible and so I also think
about I need to write legibly in this
notebook because what if someone
discovers it years from now and reads it
I want them to not think I couldn't
write good handwriting sure that's
interesting
yeah what moves you when you're writing
I think what moves me is seeing real
people go through something and
I don't know I have to really sort of
think think about it that's very that's
not a good answer hmm that's why I think
a lot of us go to the movies and and
choose certain types of movies some
people just want to be entertained and
they want a happy ending a neat little
package and and others they want to see
people go through something yeah I'm
trying but I'm trying to think of what I
want to see people go through and that's
what I think that's why I think it's not
good it's not that it's about its but I
don't think it's as accurate as it could
be because I think that things that move
me are real people in extraordinary
situations going through something that
is incredibly human and I think that
might be why I love Shakespeare so much
particularly the histories because I
will never be king of England but when I
see the King of England talk about what
it's like to be up at night and I know
what it's like to be up at night and
dealing with something then I'm now
connected in a way to what it might be
like to be the King of England it's just
the thing that keeps me up at night is
way different than the thing keeps him
up at night but the fact that we are
both have this same experience tells me
that that's another human that is going
through something that I go through and
we're connected through empathy and I
find it very moving when I see people in
these situations that I will never find
myself in but if I was in that situation
I might react the same way because that
reaction is a very human reaction that's
what moves me right this is off on a
tangent of it but just in watching
masterclass they had one on political
leadership it's not necessarily a class
I would
gravitate toward but it was just really
interesting and I love the framing of it
in the way it looked and they just
talked about how a lot of the great
presidents forced themselves Abe Lincoln
forced himself to go to the theater
different people to get out of that
mindset begins they were so focused on
what to do with this war that war and
they were criticized for it mm-hmm but
they needed that time away from it
because it did keep them up at night and
so that just reminded me of that where
they had to get away from the problem of
war and these different things for a
short time so that they could come back
and try to solve or deal with it yeah
they needed that escapism yeah I think
that art and art that is storytelling
forces us to engage with ideas of
ourselves in situations that we might
not ever find ourselves in but when
we're forced to think about that it
opens up our minds in ways that we can't
get because we don't we just don't get
that experience in the real world so I
think that we part of the reason we go
to the theater we go to the movies and
we watch TV is even if it's subconscious
it's so that we can experience these
lives that we would never experience but
because that's a human life and were
humans in a way we get to expand our
minds in ways that we need to
you